[Music]
thank you
[Music]
hey quick shout out to producer John for
that great new opening it's not new but
thank you we did it before and it's a
perfect one because we love stranger
things you guys welcome back to the
break room Our Daily Show that keeps you
updated on all dirty news that you need
to know and I know what you're thinking
stranger things stranger things I hope
that's what they were thinking Warren
stranger things because you guys it's
October we're in Halloween season and
last week we were uh I guess werewolf by
nighting
I think we did a little uh Rocky horring
we did a lot a little rocky horring a
little the werewolf by nighting and now
we're stranger thinking yeah adorable
see if you guys can figure out which
characters we each are
um today we want to start with what our
discussion is really going to be about
and a Marvel announced a slew of new
dates that are now just being pushed so
we move blade to uh September 24th from
November 3rd September of 2024.
September 24th yes what did I say you
said September 24th oh September 2024
sorry Deadpool move to now November 28th
2024 from September 2024. Fantastic Four
moved to February of 2025 from November
I'm sorry this is hurt no not your
mistakes I'm sad about the delay oh I
was like I'm sorry I'm trying oh no that
wasn't a criticism on you at all you did
great
um Fantastic Four is being moved from
February of 2025 to uh to from November
of 2024 and an Untitled movie from 11 25
2025 which was previously The Secret
Wars release date so we don't know what
that Untitled movie is could be Deadpool
we'll get back into it and Secret Wars
is now moved to May of 2025. we're gonna
get more into this later we just wanted
to start with the discussion so you guys
know at the top of the show what we're
going to get into and we will get into
it shortly yeah and and you know just
real quick this is though this sounds
like a lot of movies are being delayed
It's really because of the way Marvel
does their things it's one movie is
getting delayed and that just affects
everything else because they have these
blocks carved out they've also warned
theaters right like hey this weekend
we're going to be dropping a big Marvel
movie right and like other Studios
adjust everything and so you know they
can't just delay a movie a year and not
impact the whole rest of their schedule
because they have these very specific
release weekends set aside so hence you
know know there's no issues going on
with Fantastic Four or Secret Wars that
we know of or even Deadpool which just
got announced it's that blade right
which doesn't have a director there's
some kind of weird party we're gonna get
into it so and so that's there's this
Chain Reaction so we're going to talk
about a bunch of stuff we're going to
talk about implications on blade go back
up because you skipped absolutely
um multiple Marvel movies getting moved
Jessica wanted me to say that we're also
coming back and we're gonna we're gonna
talk about other there's other Marvel
news unrelated to these changes that we
are going to talk a lot about these
changes there's some uh She-Hulk news or
some what kind of forever news some Moon
Knight News which is very intriguing and
even uh some DC news what what's that
and also because we're not rude people
this is Brandon Barrick who we never
introduced ourselves I'm Brandon Barrick
hello welcome yes and Tommy back told
hello Two Scoops Tommy I'm playing
Maurice the backup third employee at
Scoops Ahoy who just moved to Indiana
from New Jersey after his wife
discovered he was betting on Donkey
fights how old is this guy Maurice is 38
years old someone dressed up as your New
Jersey character and tweeted it out oh
oh good I that wasn't a character that
was a real oh sorry sorry I faced into
that character by funneling a g fuel oh
god
um and then I'm uh Ted wheeler Mike's
dad people guessed it they oh wait
Mike's dead yeah so people said Mike's
dad in the chat yeah I'm actually Robin
I'm Robin from stranger things
Rob Robin these nuts no no we're done
you can't just add nuts to stuff Tommy
yeah you can I work at an ice cream shop
that's all they do
um okay yeah and and so we're leading
we're switching up the format just a
little bit and I will say there is a fun
Redemption today we appreciate everybody
in the chat and anybody that's going to
send us a super chat we'll talk about
the Redemption in a minute yeah but um
this is kind of big news it's just been
late breaking so we wanted to kind of
lead off with this uh all of the
scheduling uh implications and and a
couple of things
um it is kind of far-reaching some of
these changes and like one impact is
um we knew uh Kang Dynasty right which
is not has not moved it's still going to
be May of 2025.
um but now we know that's kind of the
infinity War to Secret Wars is end game
now they are almost exactly one year
apart on the schedule they previously
were six months apart and what else was
one year apart Infinity War name game
but here's my question here's here's
here's here's where I here's where my
little Tommy thinker goes off
in Infinity War had such an insane
ending that a year of speculation was
like oh is Kane Dynasty gonna be able to
deliver that where we're like oh like we
we gotta speculate and search for
answers and or are we just gonna be like
just get to the point that is a question
that's in the discussion do we want to
just do the discussion yes that's what
we're saying oh well scroll down I'm so
sorry I didn't know that we were doing
the discussion early hot Max
um there's more it's scroll down I'm so
sorry uh well here let's let's talk
about this real quick um so yeah I I
think like that's interesting we were
talking about it before that um we do
not yet have a director for Secret Wars
right we just got a a writer
um friend of the show Michael Waldron
come on the show uh bring Simo
um and uh as opposed to Infinity war and
end game had the same directors right
the Russo brothers did both and so it's
already a difference here in this though
we don't know Dustin Daniel Craig maybe
he's gonna pick up Secret Wars who knows
you could pick up the second one uh I
think what's most interesting about all
of this news was the way it kind of came
out today was it started with just a
story about blade being uh kind of the
production being yes put on a hold and
like but the initial article was like
there was no mention of like moving the
release date they hadn't commented on it
they hadn't said anything about it they
just said like oh we're kind of putting
this on hold right now as we search for
production had already begun yeah yeah
yeah uh because they'd already put out
like casting announcements for like
extras and things like that uh so that
happened without any other news around
and everyone was like well this is weird
I'm sure they'll announce like oh it's
being delayed that that'll probably come
out and what instantly came out was this
whole big shift of everything so I'm
wondering if if the blade story got out
earlier than they intended and they were
like well we need to like update out on
everything which kind of the
conversation has shifted from like oh
blades in trouble to like oh
everything's getting moved right now and
I'm not saying
relate is the the shift that's making
everybody it could be if they're like if
they had a plan with this character and
now they're like oh we need more time to
get this character out here then it
changes plans here and there there could
also been a series of changes that have
been made since they first rolled out
this plan over the summer at Comic-Con
like if you know if characters on
certain shows that have been out on like
She-Hulk or something feel more
important they're like well let's shift
that if shooting schedules change if
availability of actors should have
changed oh that's so true when you have
a cast that big with that many famous
people yes they're probably not gonna be
shooting them at the exact same time I
feel like they're gonna be like they'll
do it in like chunks little sections
because you remember how like Wanda was
like I never met the guy that played
right most of her stuff was shot in
reshoots when they added in a lot of her
story into Multiverse and Madness and
then again this is like a weird case
because there's no other movie studio
really doing this right making a series
of movies and TV shows that are
interconnected in a serious way they
would love to be doing it yeah but
they're not yeah so you might read all
this and be like oh this is bad news
news this is trouble blah blah but we
really don't know because it's new well
and and there's an under format there's
an underlying storyline to all uh Marvel
news recently right and this is
affecting the entire film industry is
this backlog of VFX right in that um
because so many things were delayed in
the pandemic and now they all want to
get made right now and the VFX artists
and the VFX companies are unable to
fulfill all the special effects they
need especially for huge Marvel films
right that need so much special effects
and so uh there's and and then there's
all this news about like a lot of those
artists feel like burnt out they're
abused they got to work crazy hours and
so there's uh Marvel is starting to move
some of that in-house and they're hiring
their own VFX artists but you can
imagine that's going to be a a process
that's going to take a while to ramp up
so though again this news is not
necessarily indicative of any problem
with Fantastic Four or some of these
other Deadpool or anything like that
probably Marvel's like it would also be
nice to have an extra three months to
work on some of this stuff you know it's
a little less of a rush because this is
interesting that they would still put
well yeah I guess they can't have them
all you out in the same day but I still
I think that secret project is probably
Deadpool so no no we have the Deadpool
that's another that is another just like
an extra additional but didn't they say
that they were gonna the Deadpool
doesn't it has like a new name or we
don't know the name that in this release
the it's not called Deadpool 3 it's like
an Untitled Deadpool and deadline had it
listed as like the as yet titled
Deadpool film so they might call it
Deadpool 3 and keep the Cadence they've
been doing I would think they would call
it like Deadpool and Wolverine or
something like that Deadpool lives
Deadpool kills above ground
above ground pool ah
okay guys we'll work on that one you're
not you know it's good you know it's
good when you gotta explain it right I
think it was good I think it was great
oh yeah
oh my gosh oh my gosh because that
secret film what would the secret film
be well yeah
oh does that have a sound like a soul
that was trapped inside of that haunted
stuff uh
um above ground the outside of Deadpool
or the Untitled project that we don't
know what it is that could be a
character related to a movie that hasn't
come out yet and they don't want to like
spoil it well also I mean we've long
speculated the things that are not
currently listed shangshi 2
eternals
it's an unnamed movie just because we
they don't know what the movie is yet
they're like it could be the Moonlight
some kind of X-Men and kind of property
right um there's a lot of things it
could be and I mean those are the two
options yeah they don't know what it's
going to be and they're waiting to
figure that out or they know exactly
what it's going to be and they don't
they do I think they know and they're
not telling us for important reasons yes
well we armor Wars has its release date
right well armor wears is is kind of in
The Ether now too it was going to be a
film uh show now it's going to be a film
but we don't know not slated yet so it
could be armor Wars the film could be in
there
or is they're just prepared to replace
armors at any moment there was something
else that's rude uh well another thing
we were talking about uh thank you
Jeremy Leah I'm not sure Jeremy Leah uh
I pronounce your name right um one thing
we were talking about is what's not
mentioned any of these press releases is
anything changing about the Disney plus
series
all of those are the the dates we have
we don't have that many dates are
seemingly unaffected so who knows
um we were speculating on do we think
part of the delay is uh plans for your
blade in some of these other films it
could be that I think they're busy now
adding man thing to every script yeah
okay
he is he is the grogu uh he's perfect
that thing has upset the power hierarchy
I think any any shrubs any shrub you see
on my Marvel property from now on man
thing is I feel like groot's got to be
like kidding me a lot of people on the
chat saying midnight Sons people want
the midnights I want the midnight so now
okay so let's let's check if that
timeline could possibly check out so the
the unannounced Marvel film is November
of 2025 which would make sense if blade
came out on its new November uh or
September of 2024. so like the next year
that if Blade's a huge hit and and they
could shoot some of it at the same time
you know actually I kind of like that
okay get us some Ghost Rider get us some
uh I hear them I'm sorry I'm sorry I was
gonna say I don't want to be moved to
November I wanted to be in October
foreign
October 31st 12 11 59 p.m well and
that's a great Point Jessica because
like now Blade's coming out late
September so you can watch it all during
October it was gonna be coming out at
the beginning of November so you
wouldn't have been able to watch it on
your your Halloween festival an event
film announce
is he gonna ladies and gentlemen the
Midnight Sun oh like an SNL like that
like the Twitter I think he's gonna lean
over to he'll lean over to Moon Knight
I'll be like it's midnight son
oh kind of Nag him a little bit yeah
it's corny Blade's corn not our not this
Blade no yeah we don't know Marshall
Allie's now I can walk in the day some
[ __ ] are always trying to ice
skate uphill uh is there blood coming
out of these fire extinguishers I heard
that the villain for blade is testing is
the all-time highest
villains so real quick uh thank you to
the folks that have thrown in some super
chats today's Redemption every hundred
dollars we have and this is a good one
you guys are going to want to get on
board because Tommy yeah has broken into
Netflix headquarters yeah late last
night of course a lot of people loved
some of the great 80s songs that
appeared in the most recent season of
stranger things uh Kate Bush or some
Metallica some great stuff Tommy has
stolen the songs planned for the next
season yeah I've got all I've got four
songs from season six stolen straight
out for six five season five uh I know I
have stolen the songs stranger things
straight out from under the Duffer
Brothers I stole it from them I have
them all in front of me they're straight
up bangers
they're what the kids are calling samp
delicious that's no cap not mid full
time
I don't either but it's provocative the
kids are saying it
um so yeah let's get to 100 so I can
start singing my little fart out for you
guys we want to get those parts out uh
for sure we also want to thank the folks
at Magic the Gathering arena for
sponsoring our show today hey have you
heard of Magic the Gathering Arena it
brings the vast scope of deck building
card collecting classic to your phone
write down your phone or if you're an
old man like me you can play on the
computer I'm not that old I'm only 20.
uh so that you can read all the text uh
this year Magic the Gathering is
celebrating its 30th anniversary and
it's bigger than ever in Magic the
Gathering Arena you can learn to play
collect cards challenge your friends and
build Decks that show off your favorite
fandom it doesn't matter what you're
into they got all sorts of different
like phases they have like sci-fi that's
like a new one like a horror fantasy of
course all that stuff uh Magic the
Gathering Arena it's a great entry point
to get into magic for the first time or
get back into it if you stop playing
where'd you go all you have to do is
download the game game on mobile tablet
or your desktop to play and if you're
like me and you're terrible at reading
all the rules to these games it's very
helpful because it doesn't let you break
the rules oh yes it actually taught me
how to play Magic for real this time uh
it's good I like it it's a lot of fun
you can play it too and you can get uh
helpful tips on their official YouTube
channel they have uh which has a lot of
helpful stuff on there so all you gotta
do to get started is click the link for
Magic the Gathering arena in our
description below you can download arena
for free and begin assembling Your
Dragon deck today and also check out our
YouTube channel it's very helpful they
got a lot of good tips uh We've legit
been playing Magic the Gathering Arena
independently uh enjoying it it's
bringing me back to my middle school
days when I was playing Magic the
Gathering in multiple living rooms with
my good friends yeah it's great it's
very fun I like it um okay so we're
gonna come back and talk about more of
the implications of some of these day
changes uh for the Marvel release
calendar uh but first
um speaking of Blade so uh there is is
there was a source confirmed saying that
mahershal Ali is still on board he's
still playing our favorite half vampire
uh Hunter
um he's still fully on board with blade
and will have a major part in shaping
the film's new direction right there's a
bit of a vacuum now if there's no
director so hopefully the star of that
film uh who's made a lot of great movies
and other projects will kind of fill
that vacuum and according to the source
the pause may also include more rewrites
at his request we're going to come back
to this it's a bit of a recurring thing
superhero stars that maybe rewriting
some of the rhinestones little Tom Hardy
if you want if you've got this way uh Ed
Norton Hulk uh Tom Hardy Venom uh you
can you can do some of that this is also
like a way for him to like call his shot
and get a story out there that's like oh
yeah
uh put my own spin on the movie and now
Frankie has to be like I mean is there
even now I don't believe he has directed
anything
is there a chance he angles to be star
director they don't usually like they've
never done that they've never done that
and there's not a lot of history of that
at this kind of big level
don't make me make everyone in the
office gather around me in a circle
privately after this while I do a
concert okay
our buddy you could create that throw in
a couple super chats Sammy battenfeld we
appreciate you uh uh Frey girl in there
um we'll come back if you got questions
or you got some thoughts about some of
these Marvel uh changes throw those in
Super Chat and we'll try to answer those
at the end of the show
um speaking of stars of upcoming Marvel
properties we cannot stop talking about
this in the office today wowzy wow wow
Jonathan Majors King himself did a
little photo spread for Men's Health
Magazine I think we got a photo oh my
God
oh my God oh you know I need to look
who's that dog that is a very googleable
image on the internet at any point after
this but uh you know obviously he's a
fit man he was fit in Lovecraft country
and in other projects he's playing he's
going to be a boxer in the upcoming
Creek three
um but wow I mean he's coming for that
Hemsworth Crown isn't he a spread for
Men's Health yes looking very healthy if
gaining 10 pounds is an achievement call
me an overachiever okay ten pounds of
muscle being the caveat there I think
they said uh I call it 10 pounds of
hustle
Tommy hustle over here Majors uh his
conditioning coach I like that he has a
conditioning coach uh said that he is
the warrior version of Kang so there was
a focus on what that Warrior would look
like who's been around Through the Ages
and has developed every type of combat
skill it was about making him look like
an imposing figure yeah what we have
seen of Kang is more of a a manager a
CEO a philosopher or something like that
that the He Who Remain
he's going a little crazy in that yeah
so I mean pretty cool that this variant
is gonna find a way to be shirtless at
some point is that the only photo we had
John can you send me all of them you
didn't put any more John can you Google
deep fake Jonathan majors and Delete
Men's Health but type in men's health
spread but then delete them
speaking of uh hyper-ripped uh Hollywood
actors
um uh both the Rock and Henry Cavill in
the news
the rock kind of let it slip that Henry
Cavill Superman is going to appear in
Black Adam
he's heavily implying it he's heavily
implying it we have yet to see any
footage or got any official Studio
confirmation right um but in the
interview in which he implied it he was
kind of asked do you intend to make a
movie where Black Adam fights Superman
and he replied absolutely that's the
whole point of this man well we keep
saying that the kind of tagline for this
movie is something along the lines of it
will reshape the hierarchy of power in
the dceu and like what that means I mean
I think Superman sits are like the top
of that food chain if if you're gonna
you can recycle everything underneath it
but I don't know now do you think the
way you interpret that quote do you
think he's referring to the Black Adam
film that Superman shows up in this and
maybe they have a little tussle or you
think he's trying to set up a sequel
that will be in the style of Batman v
Superman but will be Black Adam v
Superman I think that's what he could be
doing I hope not I mean I hope he shows
up what are we doing here
don't do it how do you want to see
Superman next I'll be working with Black
Adam against a giant inter-dimensional
Force
you know let's stop having the ambiguity
I know Black Adam is can be good and bad
in the comics or is usually bad but I
mean obviously he's the titular
character we're making him a bit of an
anti-hero right I don't know if the rock
is going to play a bad guy for a
franchise of movies okay I think
eventually black Adam's gonna be a
little more sympathetic I think
Superman's the bad guy but I think that
argument's best I mean that's because he
and like yeah
Metropolis well it certainly was framed
in Batman v Superman right uh what do
you think the odds are uh the rock going
up against Roman Reigns this year
WrestleMania well I know three gentlemen
that'll be there front row 500 rows up
section triple y uh we will be there get
your tickets the famous WrestleMania
sign will be right beneath it um yeah
welcome to my house is that was that oh
no that was something
[Music]
uh is that a flow writer I wonder what
the official SummerSlam or a
Wrestlemania song will be maybe it'll be
one of these four songs
thank you GSU Eagle um we're getting
there we're gonna hit that Redemption
and then once you guys hear one of these
songs boy the dollars are gonna flow
um okay we mentioned this a little
earlier Benedict Cumberbatch our our
doctor strange
um is that an interview not my doctor
said no it is strange the people's
Doctor Strange he said in an interview
that he made changes to the Multiverse
Madness script and and it gets even more
interesting he changed the script to be
more similar to Scott derrickson's pitch
for the movie you think it was rewriting
some Waldron
or or some rainy maybe I don't know so
he said in an interview that he changed
what was so the scene uh in question the
main scene we're talking about is the
between the two Stranges
um that confrontation apparently it was
going to be in one version of the
scripture it's going to be a very small
scene uh and he kind of turned it into
the bigger battle that we saw on the big
screen now I don't know if he's
scripting the like music note fight and
stuff like that but he certainly is kind
of saying he beefed out that
confrontation a lot more
beefed out yeah he beefed it out beefed
it up it beefed it up and even there it
is Jonathan major yeah
Sam what if we're here what if I say
like Abracadabra and say I was like yeah
yeah whatever you want and then they
won't even rolling the camera yeah yeah
so you think this is now Cumberbatch
exaggerating his contribution maybe I
don't know there was a moment in the
film where I said Hocus Pocus and
everybody went silent and then everybody
turned around and packed up their gear
and went home for the day because it was
so moved by my thoughts Hocus Pocus
and that was when I knew I was Dr
Strange for real I am a wizard I'm a
magic man okay you might say Hocus Pocus
but he can't say penguins
you can't there's a great video
compilation but if they cover batch
hosting one of those like planet Earth
videos and he has talked about penguins
and he says it weird every time how does
he say it he says like penguins penguins
look at the magical pen come on the show
cover back Penguins
we'll do a watch through and you tell us
what you did yes you I want frame by
frame what you're taking credit for also
we want you to pronounce all the
flightless birds okay yeah I'm gonna
need you to say emu I mean you just say
ostrich
or stretch are you riding that
skateboard no you told me I couldn't
write it and then uh he went in the same
interview he goes on to question whether
or not we'll get more into it in the
future of the MCU and see more doctor
strangers oh more Doctor Strange's more
penguin penguins look it up look at them
it feels like we need to get him in the
DC EU now so dark against penguin
penguin who is this the Ridler penguin
penguin
scared the dog hey Wayne get out of here
get ready Crow and calendar man Dr frizz
you guys are just naming characters off
now
Robin oh that was a good one night one
night wine
um it's my old friend the Kevin Dharma
how would you say Catwoman
[Laughter]
pussy.com uh Chloe Grace Moretz was
asked if she'd ever met with Marvel and
she said she had she'd taken a general
meeting with them and you know for those
on the uninitiated actors all the time
especially if he reach the status of a
Chloe Grace Moretz they have General
meetings where it's not a specific
casting or whatever but they kind of
talk about what they're interested in
get a free lunch yeah maybe some Perrier
but she what's interesting is talking
about the meeting she said she was kind
of angling she'd be most interested in
playing a villain
she was like heroes are fun but I really
want to explore the dark side
Brandon spit his drink back in there
who's your who's your um Fan cast
villain for Chloe Grace Moretz oh
probably she'd have been a good Thanos I
think
calendar okay
Jessica
what do they call Hot Tubs on Desert
Star Wars planets Jacuzzis
oh man we should have saved that for uh
uh Redemption
[Music]
[Laughter]
maybe be like a good older like x-23
right oh yeah
that don't know who Chloe Grace Moretz
is Chloe Grace Moretz isn't Kick-Ass she
plays yeah
hey girl hey girl yeah and it's worked a
ton right the
um uh Let the Right One In uh film she
was the vampire in that and tons of
movies I I don't know why those are the
only uh she's in movie 40. uh clouds of
sales Maria uh I think we all know that
Hugo
throwing you're throwing the job I think
she was in The Godfather Part three
years before she's in The Wolf of Wall
Street yeah
somebody saying in the chat Polaris
we're only pulling the best uh Max
noches suggested Chloe as magic
coming for Anya Taylor
that's what if she was Jubilee she's not
good enough to be Jubilee I think she'd
be a good health Katana is a good one I
like satana she's not really a villain
in DC isn't it yeah
I mean there whenever you look at a list
online of like characters people want to
see Moonstone comes up a lot especially
with like Thunderbolts because Moon
shows up with Thunderbolts but oh it's
like a weird I don't know no one ever
get to Moonstone yeah they need to set
her up and you know Chloe Grace
pronounce Gwen Stacy she's the biggest
I don't want her to play Gwen Stacy
because I want unless you spider Gwen
unless you spider good because I
remember that I don't want her just like
walking around yeah and she also learned
so much for Kick-Ass how to like play
with a butterfly knife and she's so good
at it I'm like uh exhaust every option
you have with her she can do flips
stunts a butterfly knife put her that's
kind of crazy how I feel about like
Zendaya too it's like yeah nice to like
get her out and then bring her back
somewhere like give her a hero you know
like let him be like Heroes interesting
she's great she's she was good in June
the little we've seen I think she's
gonna be great dude it's gonna be great
yeah
yeah she needs to I want to see some
great fight sequences from Zendaya yeah
she's she's a Nimble uh young lady who
is she in dude one of the Spice Girls
please come on let's get that Redemption
going guys
he's got his heart on his sleeve along
with a mom tattoo oh okay we'll get some
other news
um uh Oscar Isaac was that New York
Comic-Con over the weekend and he
confirmed Moon Knight's gonna be
returning we got a clip we got a clip
we're looking at a season two yeah are
you yeah are we are we are you looking
at us are we looking at season two I
don't think it's all I could say is that
it's not the last we've heard of uh
of the system that is Moon Knight
whoa okay well it's interesting editor
Kelly was there I believe I've been in
person I want to give New York Comic-Con
a little bit of a Pat in the back
because we were kind of no we were
ragging on it but we were like well the
hard part about trying to justify going
out to New York Comic-Con is we go they
don't break as much news that I feel
like there was of some pretty there's a
lot of news a lot of good news not
necessarily about like signature I mean
this is big MCU news obviously but there
was a lot of good movie news casting and
announcements broken there were they
comparing it to like San Diego I think
that's the problem is that everything
gets compared to that and even now San
Diego Comic-Con is is like you know
shares with celebration and d23 right
there's you know everything's a slightly
I hate to say watered down but at least
just more spread out New York Comic-Con
I feel like I feel like you may see the
break room there next year
whoa if you're in the tri-state area and
you attended or or from wherever you
came if you're in your Comic-Con throw
it in the chat and if you want to see us
there next year doing maybe a live break
room right wouldn't that be nuts yeah
what kind of New York City based humor
would you be doing uh there here Tommy
oh uh let me think about you really put
me on the screen who's gonna sponsor our
our podcast at New York Comic-Con
brooklinen
[Music]
it's a Ball's joke
hey you know what they say about the
Mets what what
hey by the way we would go to New Jersey
Comic Con but I'm told that it's on fire
and it has been for the last five years
and they're unable to put the fire out
the pile of tires that normally hosts
around New Jersey Comic-Con yeah yeah
that's right so wait what time will you
go to bed at New York Comic Con never
because it's the city that never sleeps
there it is how do you make a pool table
laugh tickle its balls what all right
what he's taking on actual jokes
but real quick I don't want to move on I
don't want to move on Moonlight clip
because I think it's imperative there
like yeah he's asking about a season two
and he's super cool but he's like he
will return right so does that kind of
confirm the next time we see Moon Knight
will not be a Moon Knight season two but
maybe in a film he said a system so I
feel like it's something bigger than
well that I think that's him referring
to the did of the character right that's
how the it's referred to the system into
the system of the MCU or something like
that I don't know
um is it it's a lot it's not the last
we've seen of the system that is Moon
Knight uh yeah it could be bigger than
just could be serious could be blade
could be Untitled Marvel project of uh
2024 it could be maybe he's just saying
balls in your court Kevin I just said
you put me back inside the balls we're
coming back to that all right hey all
right don't don't make that my thing how
many horses in the chat beefed up
um okay and then uh finally we got it we
got a couple Marvel videos
um there was a new teaser released for
the She-Hulk finale that's coming out
tomorrow night
um and it was almost entirely Eclipse
we've seen so far in the season except
for the briefest glimpse of the brainy
teas
a tiny teeth tiny tease
no talties this is a tiny tease of
a Hulk Bruce Banner versus Abomination
fight a little uh rematch from Harlem uh
back in the day
um what do we think it was also
interesting Abomination appeared to be
wearing clothes yeah there was like a
shot where he's in kind of like a almost
like a there it is or something like
that writing uh and this is something I
think we had seen abomination in that
get up in like an early early trailer
and that was one of those like scenes we
haven't seen yet and we didn't know if
like oh it's something they cut are they
gonna go back to Abomination at all they
weren't really sure after we're like The
Season's kind of gone but it seems like
uh they are coming back and it seems
like yeah Bruce might be back which is
kind of bizarre because we all thought
oh he's probably gone for good now yeah
do you think the sakkar storyline wraps
up over the course of She-Hulk not no
I'm sure it's like well I came back to
tell you I I just had to pick up some
things and now I'm going back for good
or I'm going now I must return to my
home planet yeah I don't know Hulk died
on his way back all right well it's also
fascinating because everything we've
seen from Tim Roth uh Emile Blonsky
right is he is full-blown reformed not
even a hint yeah yeah he's lying or he's
hiding anything right he's doing those
therapy sessions he's helping like
genuinely helping out Jennifer and
giving her good advice Jessica's been
seeing through his his facade right yes
you've been thinking that's how you say
that hiding what were you saying facade
did you say for kids
is not reformed he's just faking it
right yeah I feel like you've been
saying that I have been in that drum
I've been beating that bony horse oh my
gosh oh I can't beat a dead bony horse
you know what I mean you know you can if
it's cursed and it's come back to life
then you gotta oh my God you can't lead
a dead bunny horse I think it was in
like the third episode where she's like
talking to a meal and he's like I'm only
taking this because I wanna like I've
it's like water over the over under
bridge there's water and there's a
bridge we don't know yeah something like
that but the way he says it he's really
upset so since then I've been like I
don't think he really wanted to
apologize he's been like it did seem in
prison when he was still locked up he
did seem like shady and it all seemed
like a front but then this episode we
had with him it did seem like legit yeah
at The Retreat he still it's like you're
lying about the chicken well that that's
interesting I I tend to I've been kind
of taking my face value but I wonder
he's never been physically confronted by
Bruce right maybe that's his trigger
maybe he is reformed until he sees Hulk
and that like takes him back to the
street or maybe this has all been a game
oh
you know what's not a game Tommy we've
hit a Super Chat reduction
multiple every chance thank you thank
you to Jasmine Victor Christian
unpronounceable everybody that's been
throwing in a couple of doubloons um uh
Tommy stole some songs I did I stole
four songs from Netflix headquarters uh
this is weird though because this one
seems kind of just like another version
of Master of Puppets oh interesting so I
guess maybe if you guys just want to
like maybe give me some guitar in the
background
what just you will see we have all you
need dedicated to
educating you
we started three Sharp
sometimes three or five shots
your life is consumed
but watching break won't break room
message of the break room breaking it
down
discussions on Marvel's always about
mandatory fun till your eyes explode
hit Minecraft
break room
oh that was great
Tommy thank you I guess from Deadpool
above ground
again Tommy's got three other songs I
mean maybe I do we're only 947 away from
me releasing an album wow someone said
can I get this on vinyl and I need to
know oh it's John
uh real quick
um we want to shout out some of the
other folks that help us bring this
episode to you including our friends at
aspiration you've heard us talk about
them before hey making small decisions
every day to help the planet can have a
big impact over time you know if you're
keeping your money on a lot of these
standard bank accounts you know they're
lending your deposits out to oil
companies and coal companies and all
this kind of stuff switch to the
PlanetSide and get aspiration they're a
fossil fuel free
um company and they let you plant a tree
by rounding up every swipe of your debit
card uh they've been hard working uh
hard at work helping people align their
money with their values funding the
planting of over 100 million trees best
of all hey no credit check no overdraft
fees and with aspiration you just pay
what you think is fair even if that's
zero because money shouldn't stay in the
way of you doing the right thing make
your dollars make a difference open an
aspiration account at aspiration.com
breakroom debit and move your money out
of fossil fuels help save the planet
with your aspiration debit card open
your account at aspiration.com break
room debit today aspiration.com
breakroom debit terms and conditions
apply okay we're going to come back
there's more to discuss about these
Marvel changes that are the title and
thumbnail of this video
hell yeah
uh can I first off can I have the the
lyrics to the last one yes
these lyrics may all be available soon
oh interesting I'm not sharing mine well
there's multiple copies out on the table
oh God damn it sometimes 305 sharp is my
favorite
but you guys were going back to the new
dates that were set so there's uh like
we said earlier
um a lot of movies are being shifted if
you weren't here just go rewind back to
it
um so a lot of movies are being shifted
and one of the biggest things about this
is now there's a gap between the Marvels
and Captain America New World Order it's
like 10 months so when we get another
Spider-Man or just like more deep Disney
Plus shows or more specials what do you
think that is the weird thing right we
don't know what Spider-Man's up to I'm
sure Marvel wants to have the character
back at some point Sony they have to
work that out with Sony Sony definitely
wants to happen Spider-Man yeah but he's
also making all their other Spider Boy
movies uh in the spumcy write all these
villain movies uh but Disney doesn't get
to announce the date for the Spider-Man
movie it's not on their slate unless
that's the Untitled project but it would
seem like that would come from Sony not
from Disney we don't know uh but the the
kind of close gap between the Marvels
and Captain America New World Order when
we know the Marvel's it's probably like
the closest to being done because they
showed footage at Comic-Con that could
be very early footage still but as far
as I know from or I'm sorry d23 a d23
they didn't really say it didn't seem
like Captain America had started
shooting yet it was more like they were
they're still kind of recently writers
they've announced right on the writing
we do know the writer and the directors
right yeah but um but yeah we don't know
about that but it seems like they could
maybe catch up I mean 10 months is
almost a year right that's still some
time so they have 10 months is almost
done uh but I think Spider-Man has got
to be a part of this and somehow
especially you associate Spider-Man with
Secret Wars both versions that have
happened in the comic books the old
Secret Wars and the more recent one
Spider-Man's really important in that
yes Miles Morales is very important in
that story and like if if there is a
moment to do this introduction of Miles
Morales It's gotta happen before Secret
Wars I would think um live action Miles
Morales yeah and if they're kind of
establishing over over in the Sony verse
like Madame Webb and the importance of
Spider-Man is like a token across
galaxies or across universes like
it's got a It's gotta play into it in
some way and I think Miles Morales is
next on the Slate for Spider-Man and
maybe it becomes a situation where like
Tom Holland kind of stays with Sony for
a little bit Miles Morales comes to
Marvel for a little bit I don't know how
that's all gonna work out interesting
but yeah this gotta be like a Spider-Man
coming soon I don't think they can wait
I disagree 2025 well and it is
interesting because we know like real
soon we know Marvel's slate for the next
four years we also know a lot of Sony's
slave right Craven Madame Webb that's
delayed
um uh there's another one I'm forgetting
another Venom foreign
again the last time we saw Spider-Man
one of the largest movies of all time
right like that movie printed printing
Bank yeah um so it does feel like a
conspicuous absence right yeah and I'm
sure there'll be more shows and I think
the success of werewolf By Night
critically we don't really know it's
streaming success but I think they saw
it's very easy for them to put together
a little one-hour thing yes and be like
oh we could do these more often than we
could do a full show or a full movie
yeah so I'd love to see more of these
presentations absolutely right and just
based on traffic on some of our content
covering werewolf By Night people are
really digging it and I I think I think
not only that it out it opens up an
opportunity to find something in the
middle between a full Disney plus series
or an Epic movie it's like you only have
to make this about 50 minutes long you
can tell a kind of like isolated story
but introduce a ton of new information
it makes sense to me for them to be
doing a quarterly special things and it
is uh pardon the phrasing can be a
little bit of a backdoor pilot yeah you
know what I mean like hey
all right
check bill
I thought you were in the Navy
um yes people who fly planes no I know I
heard of Top Gun I realized that I heard
of Top Gun have you never watched it
yeah I've watched it you repeated my job
I knew I knew it and and one thing we've
talked about and you know a lot of this
too plays into that 10 month Gap the
reason it's kind of conspicuous is
Marvel's trying to like they're aiming
for that four movies a year kind of
pattern right like they they didn't get
enough this year we were getting three
but they want to start squeezing in more
because they make a lot of money and
they want to be making more money
um uh and I think we also noted there's
now three movies between King Dynasty
and Secret Wars if those are two kind of
like Infinity War in-game linchpins it's
interesting to have three full films
between there and who knows how many
Disney plus series as well because they
did two in between end game Infinity war
and end game yeah Captain Marvel and
Ant-Man and a lot of watch yeah so I I
don't know I mean
that's a big stretch it's a big stretch
through movies it's a bit of a stretch
real quick we did this earlier but um do
you want to pitch other potential
Deadpool 3 titles uh they're Deadpool 3.
I don't really feel like it
Deadpool pool of life oh I like that I
mean I like Deadpool lives is great
Deadpool returns or something like that
uh I mean I'm sure they would love to
somehow spoof
the MCU in a way like the Deadpool Saga
or something like that third time's the
charm yeah Deadpool 3-13 yeah let me in
Deadpool let me in
um Deadpool coming home oh that's what
Deadpool homecoming
Deadpool homecomer what if it's called
Deadpool in the WASP
um just steal that Captain Deadpool oh
Deadpool the Dark World oh
um
real quick Corn's yellow but you know
what's green oh greens I think our our
third and final sponsor here today who
we really appreciate athletic greens
we're a big fan of this product right
here ag1 makes it easy to get all of
your daily nutrition in one easy and
tasty drink hey Zach I have a question
if you cut your arm open and drop some
athletic Greens in do you think that'll
maximize the benefits
um unless you are a banner okay uh ilk I
don't think they recommend that
particular use just wondering uh did you
do it already no reason not yet
let's just say I might need to be a
little more athletic than I normally am
oh okay oh what a tease
um every scoop of ag1 75 high quality
vitamins minerals Whole Food Source
superfoods they got probiotics
adaptogens all the things that make you
feel good makes your body tick you know
it's like like a well-oiled machine oh
yeah mental Clarity alertness good sleep
yeah
um that's my secret I'm always sleeping
put your eyes open I I have started
taking a half of greens I drink that ag1
every day I've been doing it for like
over two months now and your skin is
incredible
you were bald a month yeah that's right
my hair's come in full yeah uh my bird
is up six inches I'm growing your beard
for you yeah yeah I'm basically a beard
farmer Brandon it's I'm radiating how
I'm a beard host I really do like
athletic greens I like a Jew one it's
very easy yeah boom in the morning and I
tell my wife I have to work out I drink
athletic greens yeah hell yeah I don't
that's it I mean you might still want to
tell my doctor take a longer vacation
I'm never coming back not part of their
pitch but you got a surgery schedule
I just rub Athletics Brandon you've been
leaking for weeks um okay now and to
make it easy hey if you click the link
in this video's description Evelyn green
is going to give you a free one year
supply of immune supporting vitamin D
and five free travel packs with your
first purchase Tommy likes the travel
package I love the travel packs because
I'm always on the run
I can't sleep in the same place two
nights in a row Thomas gotta go bad and
it's got plenty of age you want oh yeah
well I've got a few GO bags if you know
what I mean he's the the big boss of the
bug out
um all you have to do is visit
athleticgreens.com break room the name
of our show oh again that's
athleticgreens.com break room take
ownership over your health pick up the
ultimate daily nutritional insurance we
stand behind this we all enjoy this we
love our ag1 and we thank you athletic
greens for helping us bring this show
uh to the people uh Tommy yeah we've hit
200. oh this is really good news I uh so
like I said you know I broke into the
office this is crazy because this is a
yet another song that I think was kind
of used oh in previous seasons of of
stranger things uh it's called ranting
on Andor
um
Pandora yeah
so stranger things as a song it's kind
of hard to hit this it's gonna be kind
of hard to hit this key so hang on let
me just yeah
you need to watch it do you want to see
what I'm seeing
do you want to know why it's worth
watching
do you want to hear about the deal he's
making
prequel
about
Android oh baby
and if I only could I'd make a deal with
John and I'd ask him to make indoor our
thumbnail we'd only talking indoors
that's all we talk about it'd be the
greatest break room in the world If I
Only Could
yeah that was lovely again uh thanks to
the folks sending in super chats I heard
uh um TD Jones I saw in there
um some other folks again we'll try to
Circle back and answer people's
questions or read those out at the end
of the episode
um Tommy I hate to notify you of a
second thing in a row oh wow it's a
particular time of the show it's time
for mandatory fun
I said Cumberbatch pronouncing it it's
time for Monday to reform
Penguins it's time for mother toy
I don't think that's him the segment
mandatory oh Tommy's broken out
I'm from the Jersey all right anyway uh
the segment that is so fun I bring three
of my best friends in the whole wide
world together and we have a really
great time before we get to mandatory
fun we uh of those of you that watched
Andor last week you noticed that none of
the people that we had predicted would
die died because they didn't get to the
mission so we are rolling over yeah baby
those predictions uh Zach had little
baby boy nemec the little sneaky little
rat boy teenager Brandon Brandon and
cousin Richie hands cousin thanks Jeff
I'll [ __ ] you up
yeah he's got tattoos a good one I like
I like after last week's episode I like
Jessica's pick the best
Jessica's pick with this little lumpy
knobs he's got the juice he's got the
juice I just went back with my dead wife
yeah that's right and then I've of
course got Dr lady lady doctor uh that's
her name doctor lady no it's like
it's called Sybil Shepherd uh all right
anyway in celebration of stranger things
day here I thought we'd have a fun
mandatory fun scene segment
unfortunately I cannot be here today no
I can't I'm sorry I'm actually having uh
some some uh some uh some demon dog some
demo dog I'm having demo I'm having a
demo dog tongue put uh right where my
appendix used to be okay uh they say
demo dog tongues can operate as an
appendix they said my appendix was so
big they thought it was uh simply a
farmer's market gourd that had been put
inside yeah yeah Wired Magazine when
they saw my x-rays said
oh God God Henry come look at this why
was wired magazines
real quick well well uh Tommy leaves and
it will presumably be a replacement
somebody thank you Corey can drilly uh
hey hey you yeah you hit the graphic
again
he made me read it and
thank you for all your
Flanders to the Saunder
from the Ned Flanders to the to the
sander yeah okay all right trash bag
thank you TD Jones Deadpool The Last
Avenger that's a good title Deadpool
Kill The Avengers what's that Deadpool
core but like spelled like corpse
c-o-r-p-s yeah uh thank you to everybody
all right everybody
all right everybody this man's blinds
simple iPads
it's just me Duffy Duffer the rougher
Duffer brother Duffy definitely
I'm Duffy Duffer the rougher Duffer bro
oh can you can use the Eamon Targaryen
of the Denver Brothers the answer is I
can't you didn't you didn't drive here
did you oh I did I flew here oh wow I
flew here in a quinjet a quinjet we're
like a cringe
[Laughter]
pistachio hated that I'm definitely
now I've left my brothers Randy and
Sandy
duffering I have no idea
I think there's a Ross in there
Ross definitely never heard of her
anyway
definitely got for the reference
now thank you your old cosplayings
characters from my brother Sandy and
Randy duffers stranger things franchise
oh unfortunately
Sandy and Ross have a little litigation
problem right now so they had to bring
your Duffy Duffer the rougher Duffer
brother okay into produce season five
now each of your characters are alive to
my knowledge except for maybe my old
beautiful on the end there what's her
name who are you playing Eddie Munson
Eddie Munson I died that's a chick with
a dude's name what's going on I don't
watch the show
is that a man are you the only brother
that doesn't work on Stranger Things no
I work on things stranger okay it's a
haunted field it's not even a house it's
just a field of freaky [ __ ] happens
and I'm the Master of Ceremonies anyway
today's mandatory fun
each one of you is in character okay
gonna convince me why your character
needs to survive season five hit the
graphic and Jonathan Majors looking
rifty [ __ ] again
I can feel it yeah we can all feel it
wow I feel it all right who wants to go
first oh Eddie Munson I could go first
I'm already dead though how do I well
you're gonna Advocate to come back to
life one thing I've learned about things
stranger the freaky Field of Dreams
because if things don't stay dead for
long
Heaven sucks and I don't deserve to be
here I need to be brought back plus I'm
the best thing that happened to this
show in Four Seasons whoa all right and
you killed me off you gotta bring me
back from the dead cause screw this huh
Anarchy baby
I can come back I'm taking the art with
you let's go
I like that game I like your moxie
break that Daddy so punk rock
forever we used to have a guy like you
that drove the tractor on our haunted
sway ride
that's what the tractor only has one
wheel so it just goes teeter-tottering
all the way through the field rolling
over like a a whoopsie-goopsie all right
who's next I can go okay
look I'm not dead yet no but close close
I'm not well I might fight it but I
think you can bring me back and if you
brought me back I can apologize I didn't
get a good full chance to apologize for
the way I acted or my heinous brother or
anything else and I'd want to go to the
movies and I want to have my boyfriend
back and I want to listen to Kate Bush
because he's the only man that knew that
I listened to Kate Bush all the time and
I think as a young person I haven't
fully got to live yet and I would love
to come back if you follow me well looks
like Somebody's knocking on the walnut
tree pretty hard you know there's a
great song by One Republic It's Too Late
to Apologize okay wow I'm a huge fan I'm
sorry all right who's up next okay
um
I'm Duffy Duffer the rougher Duffer
brother okay well I as Ted wheeler
Mike's Dead uh have an unusually
attractive wife who doesn't seem that
into me uh that's always been a strange
recurring storyline she was gonna hook
up with her brother uh wait what he
didn't that was season four right
oh okay you're in Canon you don't know
that and Cannon I don't know you should
keep me around because I think the way
the series should end is all the
children die and only the adults are
left alive I thus take the mantle and uh
take over the role of my son I will
marry 11 and we will
she's of legal age
nuts across the fields of strange also
also Field of Dreams if you build it
they will jump feel the screams
feel the creams sir how did you get a
hold of any money I was in Vegas last
week getting dumped on by Cream Bay
check the old episodes of the break room
it's essential to watch every episode
definitely Duffer big on lore of the
Breakthrough Duffy Duffer the rougher
Duffer brother
I've made a decision my decisions are
final all three of your characters will
come back in season five wow yes in
flashbacks
real quick before we get out let's call
out MJ 2997 thank you I just now
realized that is Brandon's real hair and
not a wig a man can grow it oh is it is
it
uh film juice uh whose name might try
not to ever utter on this show but uh I
said what film in general would you
recommend for chronic shoulder pain not
Rookie of the Year
[Music]
uh 127 Hours
that's true if you think your shoulder
hurts yeah at least you're not chewing
it off yeah
um uh other folks uh Brandon can you
read any of those uh yeah uh Freight
girl asks will Donnie Blaze be an Agatha
Harkness Covenant of chaos oh I think
we've ever seen Johnny Blaze again or
was he a one and done I mean he's
married to cat Cairo so she gets to
direct more projects oh in real life
they're married yeah yeah they are
they're a beautiful couple okay we get
it they're beautiful I like some of them
you know it would be great we don't need
to give any of these uh Joke Man Bull
and and uh porcupine and all these
characters huge story lines in an
upcoming project but like his quick
cameos I think it's fun to squeeze them
in as well yeah see more of them uh uh
Christina B suggesting Rick uh fumiyama
for director of Blade question mark
oh she's starting out there is that is
that Rick's agent I don't know you tell
me can I uh really quick just add on
more to the Donnie Blaze I just thought
about this uh Donnie Blaze just got the
cease and desist he can no longer use a
sling ring and without the sling ring he
has no magic he has no power so if we
did see him in Agatha Uh Kevin her show
Okay Kevin of chaos he would just be
standing there oh as a woman or maybe
now he's desperate and he's willing to
go to darker measures to find his mask
as long as also if the end credits are
true he is in uh the dimension of me not
mirrors what is it the uh that come on
dementia the mirror Dimension thank you
oh I thought you said not the dimension
of mirror no not the dimension
uh yeah
um thank you to furl
Ernest Esteban saying Deadpool without
Vanessa equals dead pole yeah she's
gonna be a little Vanessa
um a little Vanessa Jasmine Victor thank
you film juice in there a couple times
uh thank you to everybody that was
participating in the chat today and in
the chat uh tell me we didn't hit 300
bucks yeah do you feel like we should do
one more song I could do one you know
this is crazy I I broke into Netflix's
headquarters I stole four songs and the
fourth one was kind of a dud anyway so
I'm pretty relieved that oh wait was
that the last one you sang okay
should we read a super chat now
should we read a super chat now
if we do it might be trouble
if we don't we won't make double
please don't be racist or obscene
give it to yourself if it's real me
decisions bugging me it's starting to
decision member that's not we'll look
again in season three Loki Kendra when
it says hope we get an answer is
for season two of Moon Knight you'll be
small perilous
should we read a super chat now
should we read a Super Chat
all right
Google home okay and tell me what you
see
it's not Bruce all the stories mentioned
she
she's a lawyer who just wants to date a
normal guy
every week she breaks forth walls it
brightens up our lives She-Hulk is our
leading story
foreign
Castle was Ghost Rider for midnight Suns
and then a future project turn him into
Cosmic Ghost Rider whoa now I think only
if you get our boy back as ghost right
cage you gotta get ready oh Nick Cage
let him come back he's willing to work I
think if the check's there he'll still
underwear yeah gosh yeah he's busy
looking fast gold the Blues in things
stranger you know what I'm saying
Lillian GAO I was happy to work silently
for free forever but have some cash you
trash oh thank you oh bless you Lillian
thank you uh thank you to everybody that
watched today uh we'll be back every day
this week uh no more holidays that we
know of this week um yeah today's
Tuesday Tuesday already uh we got we got
Andor dropping tonight we got the Shield
finale drop in the night after that uh
we'll be covering all that on the
channel also check out new rockstars a
trailer breakdown for the Mario trailer
should be coming out on the channel
within the next hour probably
it's not that great of a show get out of
here
I'm very into it today it's very I know
the show's getting great but I feel like
each week I can see a little more of it
which is really nice because it's so
dark every week I can see about five
minutes more gotta stop watching during
the daytime I watched it at midnight
last night stroke of midnight
uh all right we gotta get out of here uh
thank you all so much for watching
later gators gators keeping your cheater
[Music]